a police sergeant is being praised for
his role in a dramatic rescue in Georgia
newly released body cam video shows the
quick-thinking sergeant reviving a baby
boy who had stopped breathing in a
parking lot Janet shamlian has the story
for a parent a moment of sheer terror
with only seconds between life and death
but Collins family finds an angel in
Georgia police sergeant Harold Drummond
when I look down at that baby AJ I look
down to my son's face I look down to my
grandson's face his knowledge of
two-finger infant CPR would save the
life of six-month-old AJ Sherrod who's
suffering from a respiratory infection
okay he was in the right place at the
right time and he loved God to use him
to help us save the baby
angel Collins the what-ifs are
unimaginable and life would be
unthinkable without one of her twins
when you hear that baby cry and you know
hmm
it's gonna be okay you know a lot of
people don't realize that we're human
also this is my future partner you know
once strangers now connected forever for
CBS this morning Saturday Jenna
chamaeleon Waynesboro Georgia okay right
is there anything more beautiful than
there is and hearing that spring you oh
gosh what relieved a mother in that
moment is wonderful wonderful